i when i did this video where i uh got
like a really expensive cosplay made in
japan and then me made oh created yes
sorry sorry and uh [ __ ] that was hard
the whole thing that's the one with uh
yes
that was like made me realize [ __ ]
hell this is awful
this [ __ ] sucks like it was it was it
was a fun experience because i kind of
didn't need to actually do that much
yeah but i had to keep turning up to
like these sizing things
i remember like six of them yeah and it
was like okay have you haven't you
already took the measurements and it's
like resize and then we size again and
then like don't get fat because we got
to size again in two months and they
size me again like you got fat we got to
change it
yes it was a whole nightmare and then
when i finally got the costume it like
looked good in the photos but like in
real life i was like wow this looks this
sucks
really because of like i think because
the way that it was made it like and the
way that it reflected light not in
photos looks really weird
but also
like my ass is big and it definitely
wasn't made to have more room
so when i was like sitting down it was
like oh no okay i can't i can
accommodate the dumpster couldn't
couldn't could not accommodate the dumpy
could not sit down yeah just like i was
like i do not want to do this for more
than two hours yeah
that's so funny i had it off in like two
hours and i was yeah if the thought of
doing this all day made me like want to
faint yeah i was only wearing that iron
mouse costume for like
two hours to like to take the photos and
then i was like
i have like infinite respect for people
at like anime expo or like summer
conventions who are just out in full
[ __ ] cosplay i don't know just like
like because i i think like i don't know
if i don't know if he's going to be
there this year yeah but like i remember
every year at anime expo there was a
dude who dresses up in a full-on gundam
cosplay yeah made out of like cardboard
boxes and he's just like huge like it's
like you know he has like the
adjustments on his feet so he stands up
a lot taller yeah and i'm like
how are you standing out here right like
all day it's not covered in cardboard i
remember that one time we went to anime
expo and it was like during the la heat
wave oh yeah it was just like definitely
[ __ ] hot and i see people walking
around like full-on armor cosplay i'm
like how are you not dying of heat
stress right now that's when guys
figured out guy cosplayers figured out
they were like i could just cosplay as
luffy and i can have an open shirt
it's like barely any fabric on me but
what if you've got like a dad bod not
everyone wants to know whoever feels
comfortable
feels comfortable yeah if he wants to do
it then yeah it's like it's like luffy
30 years later there's plenty of scenes
where luffy is very full and he has a
big stomach
it's kind of weird yeah just say it like
that right he's robber yeah another
thing i found really difficult was
posing yes how the [ __ ] do you learn how
to pose
i was so annoyed [ __ ] what the [ __ ] did
i do they were like look this way and
then i looked that way and they were
like oh no
okay so i wonder i wonder because like
uh there are books that you can purchase
what yes there are but they're like in
like cosplay books in japan that you can
purchase and they're like these models
are incredible oh my god when you find a
good pose that you like that your body
like does what you want it to do you
spam the other living [ __ ]
it's like an emote right you just you
just spam the emotes every time pose
that i liked with my butt and it would
be like this twisty like leg up thing
that i would do and like it would like
make everything nice and tight here and
then like booty big there and like ryan
would have to get on his knees to
accentuate and everything but i was like
every damn photo shoot we're gonna get
that shot and we're gonna full send it
so i i i i agree but i think posing is
difficult do you think like from like
modeling books or like just like
standard modeling as well or is it a
little bit different i look at like a
lot of like my friends poses and stuff
like that or like people on instagram or
like you know just like on social media
and stuff like some girls just get like
the really good like super like like
lower angles or like yeah was like a
[ __ ] natural yeah she did her thing
and i was like what do i what do i do i
also think when you're in that kind of
industry where you're like your body is
your product you know yeah yeah you know
you need to know kind of like the vibe
of what yeah because when i started
doing modeling shoots i had to buy
modeling books yeah because i didn't
know what the [ __ ] to do we've done
lunch
how do i move my body yeah streetwear
too is very different kind of posing
right like you have to be really like
kind of like loose i don't even know
what i'm doing yeah exactly we've done
one shoot together and joey [ __ ] solo
carried everything he's just like do
this gun do this and i'm like oh does
this look good does it look goofy i have
no [ __ ] clue because one thing i
never got like one thing i learned on
that shoot is sometimes your body feels
really [ __ ] awkward in like certain
poses and you're like there's no way
this is gonna yeah because like like a
really common pose is to like you know
for modeling for example that i learned
is like just having your hand behind
your head like that yeah no one does
that in real life
so when you do i'm talking about joey
so when you do it in a shoot it's like
this is [ __ ] weird this does not look
good but it always ends up looking good
yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's like that's
just what i've learned the more awkward
i feel while taking a photo most of the
time it's gonna look good i remember
there was one photo i took where you
were i was like sitting on like the the
chair the stools or something yeah i'm
like i feel like [ __ ] a gremlin right
now just like sitting like this i feel
like hell i'm like there's no way this
is gonna look good and somehow it looks
great and somehow luke made it look
really [ __ ] good exactly luke is very
talented yeah very talented photographer
yeah good very good i think you guys
looked awesome the was it the suit shoot
that you guys did i thought you old yeah
yeah swag is [ __ ] thank you
did you ever have to take uh inspiration
from like models outside of cosplaying
oh yeah absolutely i think there's a lot
of like the women before us you know
like
those that walked so we could run quiver
when you said
because i'm bisexual
and women are
great women um yeah no like you take a
lot of inspiration from other like
magazines or like just stuff that you
see on tv or that kind of stuff or even
from anime you try to recreate what uh
jojo the character exactly jojo poses
yeah dude yeah
delicious that reminds me
uh
i got hats
oh yeah oh you got hats yeah oh yeah i
bought hats but they're like cursed well
i'm not really cursed um we should we
should wear them
all right
i got hats because you guys specifically
you guys are going to be in there in
california and it's going to be really
sunny outside so i figured you know just
get a couple little joke hats you know i
like your hat man i love frogs yeah i do
love frogs
speaking
of cold for you
all right all right all right all right
all right finally yes how do you not
have that already i do now there you go
there you go i love how i love the
orange as well yeah it's such an ugly
orange it's really ugly it [ __ ]
happens
oh my god
i'm so thank you mom for making me an
only child
where did you get this from i just got
on amazon i was like i was like so guys
i can love mill
guys do you want to take a trip to
alabama quickly yeah
well here in the us okay do you remember
when you were like obsessed with that oh
[ __ ] what up is that boy yeah of course
[ __ ] yeah
oh [ __ ] what up is that boy
oh my god i didn't know they made these
i also have a secondary milf hat if
anybody wants to uh you know change
teams what is it can i say it's it's
black i think you should keep the other
one
you need the orange i don't know i don't
look good in hot slopes what are you
talking about it looks awesome actually
that suits your shirts that actually
suits you
what the [ __ ]
one step closer to becoming the dad now
[ __ ] what up is that boy
thank you
oh my god thank you for my new gift i
actually will use this thank you it's a
good hat i think so too i like it well i
guess i know what i'm wearing what do
you look like why do you look like a
truck driver yeah this is a truck
driver it's a truck
yeah you so much for my gift
you're welcome thank you very much thank
you i'm gonna wear it for the rest of
the episode